[Music]
normally each week i'm joined by my
sidekick and real-life friend
tarek davis but tara couldn't be here
today so this week i'm joined by my
real-life friend jeff wright
hi jeff hi amber jeff recently moved to
new york city from orlando and he
loves the snow i hate it he thinks
blizzards are fun
they're terrifying he spent all week
sledding in central park
i spent all week googling orlando plus
return flights
you wouldn't dare you guys it's been a
crazy week in america
let's find out what happened according
to a report from the southern poverty
law center
at least 160 confederate symbols
were removed last year from public
spaces like this one
vice president kamala harris recently
sold her san francisco condo for over
three hundred thousand dollars more than
what she paid for it
so if you're having trouble selling your
home my advice is to become the first
black female vice president
of the united states the last kmart
store in boston recently closed
kmart or as it's known in boston k
marty mark and the funky bunch
[Laughter]
we make our own fun the principal chief
of the cherokee nation recently asked
automaker
jeep to retire its cherokee brand name
said the washington football team can we
have it
the principal chief of the cherokee
nation added that it does not honor them
to have their name quote
plastered on the side of a car said jeep
we hear you
we respect you we'll move it to the roof
new york city's movie theaters will
reopen next month
at 25 percent capacity also known as a
great crowd
for an improv show
some of these jokes are for you
that much is true but some of these
jokes are just for me
[Music]
according to a new study female
economists are more likely to be asked
patronizing or hostile questions than
their male colleagues
said their male colleagues hey sorry
quick question
says who
and finally a puppy born recently in
oklahoma city
has six legs and two tails so you know
what that means
64 more weeks of coronavirus
and that was the monologue hey jeff
did you like the monologue i did okay
what was the funniest part
the part where you lied about me liking
snow okay all right you know what you're
gonna it's gonna
start to grow on you and you're really
gonna like it and then you'll feel sorry
okay but hey aside from telling lies
about me wasn't there something else you
wanted to talk about
oh oh yeah you guys i wrote a book
look at it i wrote it with my sister
lacey lamarr and it's called you'll
never believe what happened to lazy
crazy stories about racism you might
think the best part of writing a book is
having your name on the cover or seeing
it in bookstores
but you're wrong the best part of
writing a book is that you get to
dedicate it to someone and
we dedicated our book to 80s pop
superstar
and lacey's childhood crush aleda barge
she loves them so bad no one loves
anything
more than lacey loves elder barge so
if you're looking for something to read
pick up a copy okay so
we actually have one more monologue joke
for you guys tonight
but as a special little treat jeff is
gonna tell this one instead
this is amazing i've been waiting for
the day i finally get to tell my first
monologue joke
should i just do it now yeah go for it
president biden is reportedly
considering a ban on new oil and gas
drilling on federal land
and you know what they say all's well
that
ends well
[Laughter]
that's a good joke i love it
you stole my big monologue joke oh
oh man i'm i'm sorry i look i i saw the
cue cards and i just got too excited
oh my gosh i almost forgot another
special thing about today's episode is
we have our very first audience member
say hello to randy
hey amber randy we're so happy to have
you here
how are you liking the show so far are
you kidding i'm loving it what a dream
come true
and i got to tell a monologue joke
sorry about that man again oh don't
worry that's not that big of a deal
right jeff
now it's time for our brand new segment
called look at these swords i found
this is a very special segment of the
show where i
whoa what just happened who knows
i guess the lights must have
mysteriously gone up oh
that's so strange anyway let me show you
these swords i found
hey wait a minute there's only one sword
here
what happened oh no randy
[Music]
oh my god who would do something like
this
i can't believe it not randy anybody but
randy
we gotta do something call 9-1-1 don't
worry randy we're going to figure out
who did this to you
i know exactly who did this it breaks my
my
heart to say it but it was it was it was
yes
tell us who wasn't randy
oh my god they stabbed randy again
[Music]
why would somebody kill randy and why
would they use my beautiful swords and
what on earth is going on with these
lights i don't know
must be a rat in the wires or something
that's not the only rat in here
something's afoot somebody in this room
killed randy
somebody who had the opportunity to grab
my swords somebody who had a motive to
do it
and somebody who had access to the
lights and i think we all know exactly
who it was
jeff me
oh no i'm not accusing you i was just
gonna say you got a little something on
your hands like a jelly or something
oh thanks for looking out you know i'll
just wipe them on this shirt i have
right here
great anyway the killer is wally well
they did it
no i didn't no
oh well all right then i gave it a shot
we don't have time for all this nonsense
let's move on
get that body out of here
now we've covered a lot of news tonight
but the most important news is
that it's black history month now if
you're looking for ways to celebrate i
saw a trailer the other day for the
perfect movie
take a look
[Music]
in theaters this spring you've heard of
harriet tubman's bravery
the way we're getting treated here will
not stand
her courage and i have a plan to get out
i'm gonna escape this plantation her
fearlessness
and then i'm gonna come back for all of
you
finally a film that tells the truth
about what drove her to greatness
and i'll tell you why i'm coming back
for you because
i have a dream to see black people free
no to end inequality not quite to
destroy the economic system that relies
on our enslavement
for other people's profit no nothing
like that
what is it then to be on the 20
bill harriet's dream the true story of
what motivated one of the greatest women
in history
[Music]
i can't run anymore yes you can go on
without me
no i'm taking you north so you can have
a wonderful
life so you can get married and have
children who have children
who have children who have children and
then those children
those children will be free no those
children will
see my face on the 20 bill
[Music]
the true story of her personal life
harriet you don't have to keep going
back for them you've done enough
enough to be on the five maybe or the 10
but not enough to be on the 20.
what and the true story of her legacy
miss tubman i owe you everything
i'll honor your memory by working every
day of my life
to end our oppression or could you get
my face on the 20.
i i don't see how it's easy i made a
prototype
you see it coming this february
it's the story of an icon
follow me to freedom yeah and when we
get there
let's change the way money looks
come on guys
harriet's dream why have
real change when you can have a symbol
on a piece of paper
i have my own youtube channel now yay be
sure to subscribe for a lot of show
clips and a lot of digital exclusives
and a lot of this
you